comment est ce que vous avez jugé une
nouveau secrétaire d'état aux retraites
c'était un naufrage il n'y a pas
d'autres mots c'est titanic
franchement cette réforme est soi disant
travailler depuis deux ans il a fallu
que le sénat parce que vous l'avez pas
pressé mais c'est le sénat qui s'est
saisi de cette question et qu'elle
souhaitait mener ce débat là monsieur
retraites donc celui qui est le plus à
même qui serait le plus à même de
connaître le dossier vient au sénat qui
t'arrive il ya trois semaines un cas
pris la suite de jean paul ii le voir
c'est pas nouveau c'est pourquoi est il
parti monsieur doit pas faux mais tout
ça en contexte il arrive là et il vient
et c'est un naufrage totalement
incapable imaginez bien incapable
pendant plus de deux heures données de
donner le moindre chiffre
quant aux conséquences de cette réforme
mais si je peux dire un mot sur la
réforme
mes services et la compétence de leurs
emplettes rachesky pour vous ou c'est le
flou global de l'âge avancé sur le flou
global je crois que tout cela illustre
on nous en sommes premiers éléments pour
que vos téléspecteurs comprenne bien il
ya un aspect soit disant financier
disons un mot dessus le précédent
quinquennat a permis d'avoir un
équilibre du système de retraite
français il l'a sauvée et donc
d'ailleurs le conseil d'orientation des
retraites a dit en 2017 en 2018 qu'il
n'y aurait pas de problèmes financiers
et puis il ya quelques mois un nouveau
rapport a dit qu'il n'aurait 1
pourquoi tout simplement parce que c'est
la politique de ce gouvernement là qui a
réduit le nombre de fonds d'agents de la
fonction publique et qui ne recueille
fait des allégements de cotisations sans
les compenser au budget résultat des
courses c'est ce gouvernement là qui
crée un déséquilibre dans le système
actuel et il ya moins de recettes et il
vient dire ensuite il ya le feu au lac
oui ce par son incompétence et par sa
politique ça c'est le premier élément
est sur cet aspect là sur l'aspect
financier c'est donc ce gouvernement qui
est responsable de la situation
alors il dit il faut trouver un
équilibre doux l'âge pivot
je rappelle que sur ce point là c'est
très intéressant puisque c'était une
ligne rouge vous le savez de quasiment
tous les syndicats la cfdt en tout cas
c'est très clair oui des autres aussi de
trois syndicats veulent mais
sa retraite hôtel veulent pas de cette
avis vaut donc tous les syndicats sauf
il faut le dire il ya un autre ligne
rouge que personne n'évoque celles
posées par le medef sur pas de hausses
de cotisations alors quand c'est le
medef le gouvernement dit on touche ma
ligne rouge
quand c'est les syndicats de salariés le
gouvernement piétine cette nuit rouge il
ya deux poids deux mesures ça c'est sur
le seul aspect financier et la vérité de
la chp d'âge qui vont ou l'âge des clips
ou du poète simple du retrait du recul
pardon de l'âge de départ des français à
la retraite ce une raison simple c'est
une course poursuite entre heller et
l'hérault m
je m'explique au moment des élections
européennes vous avez vu une partie
lectorat de gauche qu'ils aient voté
pour mac on est reparti et il a été
remplacé cet électorat par celui de la
droite et donc dans ce cadre là le goût
premier ministre qui pense à son avenir
lui se dit il faut prendre un totem pour
garder l'électorat de droite donc le
départ à la retraite à 64 on est bien
sur la droite dévalant la vraie réforme
c'est 65 ans donc sur l'équilibré
financier sur l'âge pivot c'est d'une
part la politique du helmand qui nous
met dans cet état là et c'est le la
course poursuite entre la droite et vous
en tirer comme conclusion quel est pour
vous le but ultime du gouvernement que
en s'obstinant sur à faire de cet âge
pivot de mai de garde et de maintenir
des l'écrire noir sur blanc dans le
projet de loi cet esprit vous pour
quelque chose les chirurgiens des choses
sont simples à la fois garder
l'électorat de droite qui de la rejoint
et dans le même temps il ya une vision
libérale et faire en sorte que
effectivement il faut qu'il compense sa
politique saisissant d'équilibriste un
peu difficile at et 90 de faial
équilibre sauf pour les français parce
que ceux qui paient l'addition
ce sont les français ça sur cette partie
là il ya une autre partie sur le stand
où globalement si je peux dire un mot
d'abord il faut rappeler aux français
que ce système en france
il permet d'avoir c'est toujours trop 7
% de retraités pauvres
quand vous avez le double dans tous les
autres pays donc finalement il ya du bon
alors il ya des inégalités système
actuel ce thème il ya des inégalités en
système actuel est on le sait sur la
question la pénibilité sera pas que ces
événements qu'il a retirés sur la
question des femmes etc
les carrières longues qui affecta donc
moi ce que je dis bah travaillons sur
les i
qualité puisque tout le monde les points
tout le monde les connaît
alors que la caisse qui proposait
franchement le gallon propose de aux
français de sauter dans le vide en leur
disant vous inquiétez pas le parachute
s'ouvrira enfin c'est pas sérieux
s'cusez moi dans quelle famille dans
quelle collectivité
on peut dire aux français voilà on va
modifier une enveloppe qui représente
14% du pib français pour des dizaines et
dizaines d'années sans aucun chiffre
sans aucune étude d'impact sérieuses et
irresponsable c'est scandaleux donc pour
ces raisons là il faut retirer tout cela
et moi j'en appelle un vrai grenelle sur
les retraites comme je les dis prenons
les questions des inégalités
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
travaillons là dessus et je crois que là
sur cet aspect là cette démarche là les
syndicats de salariés et d'employeurs et
l'état et les parlementaires trouve dans
un accord pour